I don't want to overstate the importance of
the growing Donald Trump battle with fox news
because Trump and fox news getting along slightly
less well, as I've been telling you that they're
getting along slightly less.
Well, it doesn't really alter that in the
big picture.
When you zoom out, Fox carries water for Trump.
Most hosts still worship the guy's every word.
You've got Hannity, Tucker, Jeanine, Pirro,
whatever.
Trump might even see the increasing battle
that he has with Fox News.
Uh, w really only Shepard Smith and sometimes
Chris Wallace and some of the weekend hosts.
Trump might even see it as sport and a way
to get publicity by attacking Fox.
But the reality is that we don't want to overstate
the importance of that conflict between Trump
and some elements of Fox News because overall
they're still on the same page.
And Fox is mostly a pro Trump propaganda outlet.
But the disagreements between Fox and Trump
have now spread beyond just Shepard Smith
and occasionally Chris Wallace.
And once, I believe Neil Cavuto, even now,
Bret Baier is having reporter John Roberts
simply say, Donald Trump's bogus sharpie altered
map of Hurricane Dorian is merely that it's
bogus.
It was never part of the original forecast.
Now, I already told you in the last story,
uh, exactly how this map was presented.
Donald Trump previously saying hurricane Dorian
was on track to hit Alabama.
It wasn't Trump then tried to retroactively
defend that claim by using a sharpie.
Not Saying he personally did it, but someone
did a to make it look as though Alabama was
within the reasonable a cone or trajectory
of that, uh, Hurricane Fox News then reported
on this and they didn't fall for it.
They said this was a bogus altered map.
Take a look.
John, you were in the Oval Office today for
that pool spray.
Um, this afternoon, the president displaying
a hurricane forecast map, but there appeared
to be a change made to it.
What would happen?
This was following a briefing from Kevin Mcaleese
and the acting secretary of Homeland Security,
uh, and as well the comment onto the coast
guard.
This is a forecast track that the president
held up from last week where it looked like
the hurricane was going to slam it in the
Florida coast, maybe even crossed the potential
and get into the Gulf of Mexico.
You can see somebody with a sharpie or some
other writing instrument added a little bit
to the cone of uncertainty, which was not
part of the official forecast, which included
the Florida panhandle and parts of Alabama.
President Trump had tweeted over the weekend
that Alabama appeared to be in the cross hairs
and you could probably extrapolate that if
it had have continued on that track.
Alabama might've been effective, but it was
never part of the official forecast.
When asked this afternoon how that marketing
got on the map, the president said he had
no idea.
Right.
Okay.
John, Robert, Slava in the north lawn.
John, thank you.
This
is hilarious, but I really want to make an
effort to provide the right context for these
stories.
Okay.
When it comes to this Fox versus Trump thing,
let me zoom out a little bit.
Fox News and even corporate media more broadly,
our what we call sense-making tools and they
are terrible sense-making tools for society.
So when we talk about sensemaking and media,
this is maybe one of the most important analyses
that we can do.
And I get it.
We're, we started with a Sharpie, but again,
I'm making an effort to really provide broader
and important contexts for when we do these
media analysis stories.
When we talk about, uh, the sense-making analysis
for media, it goes well beyond the propaganda
value of media.
We've talked a lot about the propaganda value
of media and how media can sort of serve corporate
interests or political interests for one party
or another party.
And you really have to zoom out to understand
this.
We are an estimated on this planet.
We are an estimated 7.7 billion people, each
kind of existing in our little corner of it
only having an awareness of a tiny, tiny fraction
each day of what happens on our planet.
A nearly infinite, I know that that's not
a precise term, nearly infinite, but I think
people know what I mean.
A nearly infinite number of things.
It takes place every day depending on how
you measure them.
Births, deaths, violence, storms, crimes,
entrepreneurship, food, growing medicine,
technology, right?
I mean it's like the, the list doesn't do
it justice because think about everything
that goes on in our planet in one day.
Sense-Making is giving meaning to what goes
on in our world so that we can understand
it because again, so much happens every day
that the mind cannot actually comprehend it.
So sense-making is giving meaning to, to things
that are going on and this is actually what
corporate media serves on a plate for us.
We can't possibly follow every development
that takes place on our planet.
So what media does is not only do they explain
things to us, but they also narrow the scope
of what we pay attention to.
And by virtue of that, they assign meaning
to what areas of life should we be paying
attention to.
Local News, your 11:00 PM local news takes
everything that happened in the day and it
makes sense of the world by picking, you know,
it's usually like five stories.
One or two are usually about some horrible
crime that took place.
They give you the weather and then a couple
of other stories and that's how they make
sense of the day.
For you.
And as I've talked about countless times about
corporate media, there is really no one media
outlet including me.
I mean I'm including myself in this.
There is no one media outlet that can really
do sense-making justice because there's just
too much that happens in the world.
So to be an informed person, I've talked about
the knowledge pyramid before.
Oftentimes when I go in, I talk to uh, at
colleges and universities about critical thinking
and epistemology.
The Knowledge Pyramid is this thing that you
have to build up.
And the bottom of the pyramid is critical
thinking skills, epistemology skills, learning
how to think, learning how to learn.
You then build the pyramid further by taking
those epistemological skills and you want
to gain subject matter knowledge about sociology,
culture, physics, math, whatever, right?
You get subject matter knowledge.
And then at the very top of the pyramid is
sort of like what happens day to day.
You have to use that entire base of the pyramid
to interpret a specific event to solve a specific
math problem.
For example, when you think about knowledge
this way, Fox News, calling Trump out or not
calling Trump out really doesn't make a big
difference in terms of foxes bigger picture
sense making capacity.
But when we think of the universe in which
your average Trumpist is operating, people
who don't have the epistemology and critical
thinking foundation, people who have not used
that foundation because they don't have it
to gain subject matter knowledge for them,
their pyramid is truncated.
And in those cases it actually can make a
difference that Fox News is saying the sharpie
image was completely bogus.
It could pierce someone's echo chamber, it
could get someone to rethink their sense-making
choices and it is still a good thing.
That is a lot of context.
But this is I think how we need to be thinking
about this very public sort of pseudo battle
between Donald Trump and fox news and Fox
News occasionally saying what you are saying
there isn't true.
What Donald Trump said simply doesn't correspond
to the facts.
And I think that if we want to be informed
news consumers and really be thinking about
these things more broadly, it's fun to watch
Shep Smith say Trump's a liar.
But we want to actually understand the context
and in the context for an audience that is
so lacking that critical thinking pyramid
and the subject matter knowledge, it could
actually get them to say, you know what, maybe
this guy is a liar and I shouldn't support
them in 2020
and to that extent, I think it's great.
Let's just not pretend that Fox News is not
still 95% carrying water for Donald Trump
and effectively functioning@statethedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com